C'était hier ou plus avant-hier et en ce milieu du XVIIIe siècle, alors que les États-Unis ont déjà 23 millions d'habitants, la plus grande puissance européenne en a 36 millions seulement.
5 villes américaines ont 100 000 habitants ou plus.
New York en a 500 000, déjà parqués entre Washington Square et Union Square.
Manhattan, Brooklyn, ce sont quelques maisons de campagne difficiles d'accès.
Chicago a environ 10 000 habitants. Dallas doit en avoir tout au plus 300.
Il y a peu de chemin de fer.
Estro, pourquoi tu nous parles jamais des indiens ? C'est vrai, pourquoi ?
Pierre, on n'a pas tort, on ne les voit jamais attaquer des convois comme dans les films.
Et scalper des blancs !
Il faut que vous sachiez, les enfants, que les choses ne se sont pas passées exactement comme ça, voyez-vous.
On a été particulièrement injustes envers les indiens, on a terni leur image.
Ça donnait meilleure conscience.
En fait, en quelques décennies, ce peuple courageux et fier a été presque exterminé par l'action néfaste des blancs.
Mais retournons un petit peu en arrière.
En 1804, le président Jefferson charge deux officiers, Clark et Lewis, d'aller explorer le Far West et la Louisiane qui vient d'être cédée par la France aux États-Unis.
Ces bisons sont notre bien le plus précieux.
Ces terres sont immenses, mais elles sont inhabitables et inexploitables, président Jefferson.
Ah oui, eh bien au moins comme ça, nous sommes fixés.
Réservons donc les bonnes terres de l'Ouest à nos pionniers et rejetons les Indiens dans les déserts de l'Ouest.
Vous êtes sur nos terres. Vous abattez nos armes.
Question, on est chez nous ici.
Que les indiens aillent à l'ouest, au-delà du Mississippi, je ne veux plus en voir un seul de ce côté du fleuve.
Et les cinq tribus civilisées, Président Jackson, les Creex, les Choctaw, les Chiroquis, devons-nous les laisser sur leur terre ou non ?
Emmenez-les de l'autre côté du Mississippi, dans le désert de l'Oklahoma.
Promettez-leur tout ce qu'ils veulent et si ça ne suffit pas, employez la force.
Les Chiroquis, pour obéir, ils s'étaient américanisés.
Ils avaient bâti des écoles, des églises, des tisans, agriculteurs.
ils avaient 30 moulins, 10 siries, 60 échoppes de charrons, 300 charrues, 700 métiers attissés.
Éleveurs, ils avaient constitué un cheptel de 22 000 têtes plus 8 000 chevaux, 46 000 pour ça.
30 000 hommes seront déportés.
« Vous pouvez aller vers d'autres terres plus propices à votre bonheur », avait décrété Jackson.
Des milliers d'entre eux périront en route.
On leur promit que leur nouvelle terre leur appartiendrait aussi longtemps que les arbres pousseront, que les fleuves couleront.
Une drôle de promesse qui ne sera pas plus tenue que ne le seront les centaines et les centaines de traités signés avec les Indiens.
Dites-moi les Indiens, Jackson.
Pourquoi ? Peut-on détester les autres quand ils sont différents ?
Je sais, c'est une question que je me suis bien souvent posée, les enfants.
Eh oui, eh oui. Les Indiens n'étaient ni des anges ni des saints, seulement des hommes.
Sans doute est-il rassurant de penser que nos excès et nos insuffisances sont la faute des autres.
Quand nous avons meurtri et spolié tous ces autres si différents, il nous faudra encore les réduire et les humilier pour mieux nous justifier.
C'est notre destin manifeste de nous répandre sur ce continent que la Providence nous a alloué.
Voilà ce qu'écrivait en 1846 un dénommé John O'Sullivan.
Cette belle théorie va permettre la conquête du Texas, après l'épreuve d'El Alamo,
puis celle du Nouveau-Mexique, de la Californie.
Il y avait eu entre-temps, en 1846, l'Oregon.
Il était temps, car on n'allait pas tarder à découvrir de l'or de l'Ouest.
Mais pour cela, il faudra un chantre de l'Ouest, le grand explorateur John Frémont.
C'est probablement le point culminant des rocheuses.
Je sens qu'on va encore se faire une ascension.
On fait une ascension très périlleuse à travers neige, glace et tempête.
J'ai dû franchir les parois verticales des précipices et m'accrocher souvent au rebord de Crovasse sans fond.
Nous allons nous séparer en deux groupes.
Que vous suivrez la rive, Preuss, Jessie et moi, on descendra les rapides.
La relation de ce pays s'avère pleine de dangers, nous avons failli nous noyer lors d'une descente de rapides.
Ainsi qu'à la suite de la campagne de Frémont, des milliers de chariots sont partis à la conquête de l'Ouest.
Mais vous avez déjà vu cela.
Les indiens dans tout ça, qu'est-ce qu'ils deviennent?
Bien sûr, les pionniers vont vite se répandre sur le territoire qu'on avait donné aux Indiens pour qu'ils puissent y vivre jusqu'à la fin des temps.
Souvenez-vous, aussi longtemps que les arbres pousseront, que les fleuves couleront.
Voyons d'abord les Indiens du Sud, les redoutables Apaches, leur chef, Cochise.
Au début, il fraternisera avec les Américains, les croyants différents des Mexicains qui ont massacré par traîtrise, son père et ses quatre frères.
Il leur accordera même le droit de construire un relais près de l'Apache Pass, domaine.
Mais Cochise, à son tour, va être victime d'une félonie.
Un jeune lieutenant, frais et moulu de West Point, l'invite un jour à une rencontre.
Compagné de sa femme, d'un de ses enfants et d'autres membres de sa famille, le chef Apache s'y rend sans méfiance.
Avec trois balles dans le corps, Cochise va rejoindre les siens.
Et cet homme qui désirait la paix va se trouver contraint de se battre, ce qu'il fera avec rage, sans concession.
La sécession vient d'éclater.
Pendant dix ans encore, Cochise va continuer de se battre, harcelant les voyageurs, les prospecteurs, les colons.
Et lorsque Cochise meurt, une autre figure de légende, l'Apache Jeronimo, va reprendre le combat.
Et ce, jusqu'à ce que ses troupes soient décimées.
Regardez bien attentivement la carte. Voici où se trouvait le pays Apache,
et ici l'Apache passe, où vient de se dérouler l'action que je viens de vous conter.
Remontons maintenant plus au nord, jusqu'au pays des Cheyennes et des Sioux.
Comme les Apaches, ce sont là des peuples fiers, indépendants, valeureux à la guerre.
Corruption des Blancs les a à peine entamés.
Le métal jaune qui les intéresse tellement n'est pas inépuisable, loin de là.
Quand ils en auront assez, les hommes blancs partiront de nos terres.
Ça doit être bien louré, vous allez bien gentiment vous délaisser pour vous aider un petit peu.
Attends !
Dollars symboliques qu'on a donné à chaque pionnier, un lot de 64 hectares.
Et peu importe sur les terres qui ont été allouées par traité aux Indiens.
Lissons les barrières des visages pâles, Crazy Horse.
Elles empêchent les bisons d'arriver à portée de nos flèches.
Ce serait la guerre.
Pour ça, nous avons besoin de l'accord et du concours de tous nos frères.
C'est alors que pour sécuriser les colons, le gouvernement décida de construire une piste flanquée de fortins entre Fort Laramie et Virginia City dans le Montana.
Ce sera la piste Bosman, en plein cœur des territoires de chasse des sioux.
Pour nourrir nos femmes, nos enfants, la famine s'installe, nuages rouges.
Et maintenant, ils construisent des forts sur nos terrains de chasse.
Nous affamés. Et après, nous parquerons dans leurs réserves pour mieux nous avoir à leur merci.
Souvenez-vous de Sand Creek.
300 Cheyennes ont été massacrées alors qu'ils étaient sous la protection de l'armée américaine.
Nos amis Cheyennes survivants sont venus se joindre à nous et ils réclament vengeance, nuages rouges.
Il faut démolir leur enclos et leurs barrières.
Attaquons leurs fangs !
Écoutez-moi bien, mes frères.
Quand le père à tous de Washington nous a envoyé son chef soldat,
on nous a dit qu'il voulait seulement passer à travers nos territoires de chasse
pour aller chercher le métal jaune dans l'ouest lointain.
Nous avons fait preuve de bonne volonté et nous avons laissé le serpent se glisser parmi nous.
Et voilà que maintenant les blancs s'installent tranquillement sur nos terres.
Ils font fuir les bisons, ils construisent des forts.
Ouais, ouais, il a raison, Nuage Roux.
Voilà pourquoi je préfère mourir en combattant plutôt que mourir de faim.
Mes frères, je suis pour la guerre.
Musique y parle plusieurs fois.
Nous ne sommes pas assez bien armés pour les attaquer de front.
Nous allons nous battre autrement.
Ce soir nous coucherons à Fort Kenny.
Ces derniers peaux rouges ne comprennent que la manière faite.
Ils savent que nous sommes les plus forts.
Je me fais fort de battre les sioux à plate couture et traverser le pays de long...
Vous connaissez malicieux, Capitaine Fetterman.
Et moi, Général Carrington, je m'engage à vous rapporter le scalp de nuage rouge et celui de Crazy Horse par-dessus le marché.
Nous donnons une telle leçon à ces sauvages de quoi les dégoûter.
Que le ciel vous aide à les vaincre, Capitaine Brown. Entrez !
Au Général, nos bûcherons et leur escorte viennent d'être attaqués au fortin du bois.
Qu'on dépêche à leur secours 30 cavaliers épaulés par 150 fantassins !
À vos ordres !
Entendu, prenez le commandement, Capitaine Fetterman. Le Capitaine Brown vous assistera.
Mais faites attention, messieurs. Ne poursuivez en aucun cas les Indiens. Est-ce bien compris ?
C'est ainsi que finir le bravage capitaine Fetterman et ses malheureux soldats.
Familles indiennes au grand complet, femmes, enfants, vieillards, tous sont venus au spectacle pour voir en action leurs valeureux guerriers.
Mais toutes les batailles ne seront pas toujours aussi favorables aux Indiens.
Eh bien, les braves laisseront leur vie sous le feu des canaux, des mitrailleuses, des fusils à répétition.
Mais la combativité, la résistance des peaux rouges, en fait impression à Washington.
Après une enquête, une commission déclare que la route du Montana et ses forts sont contraires au droit.
1868, à Fort Laramie, on offre la paix aux Indiens.
Black Hills appartiennent à notre peuple, la paix oui, mais que les soldats blancs évacuent nos terres et nos terrains de chasse.
Ce sera là une des rares victoires indiennes.
La piste Bosman est interrompue, l'effort évacué.
Mais ce sera une victoire éphémère.
Le général Sherman ne voudra pas rester sur une défaite.
Chasse reprise dans les vallées verdoyantes comme au temps des plus beaux jours.
Plus à l'est, dans le pays, des hommes travaillent à la ligne de chemin de fer.
Bisons, là-bas ! Allons-y, les gars !
Pour chasser, les bisons vont petit à petit disparaître.
Trois millions de bêtes seront abattues chaque année.
Buffalo Bill va, à lui seul, en tuer plus de 4000 dans une année, ce qui lui vaudra sa réputation.
Bien sûr, les Indiens vont réagir devant le massacre de leurs principales ressources.
Eh bien qu'il continue, je suis convaincu que les chasseurs de bison feront plus pour régler cette irritante question indienne
que l'armée n'a pu en faire en 30 ans de combat.
Écoutons, Général Terry.
Le gouvernement a décidé de construire une voie ferrée entre les Big Horn et les Black Hills, messieurs.
Quel prix demandez-vous pour les Black Hills ?
Depuis que Nuage Rouge s'est retiré, c'est Sitting Bull, le taureau assis, qui a pris la tête des guerriers sioux.
Tout ce que nous demandons, c'est que vous respectiez les traités que les hommes blancs ont signés, voilà quelques lunes.
Les Black Hills sont des terres sacrées, la demeure des dieux.
Nous n'y voulons pas d'hommes blancs.
Ne sortez pas de vos réserves et les traités seront respectés.
Le Grand Esprit nous a donné ce pays pour y vivre.
Lorsque vous êtes arrivés chez nous, nous vous avons accueillis en frères
et voilà que maintenant vous tuez notre gibier et vous essayez à tout prix de vous approprier nos terres.
Nous ne voulons pas votre civilisation.
Nous voulons vivre comme vivaient nos pères.
Respectez les traités que vous avez signés en vivant en paix avec nous,
sinon retournez d'où vous êtes venus.
Connaissez la puissance des armées américaines ?
Nous allons devoir considérer comme rebelles ceux qui sortiront des réserves.
Ils seront châtiés.
Le général Jibon et ses hommes quittent les Fort Ellis pour mater les Indiens.
D'autres troupes partent à leur tour de Fort Lincoln et sous le commandement du général Crook.
L'armée envoie en reconnaissance les éclaireurs indiens dont elle dispose maintenant.
S'enfuie, chef !
Au 7e régime en cavalerie, vous localiserez le camp des rebelles qui nous ont été signalés.
Avec vos hommes, vous le contournerez pour le prendre à arvers pendant que nous l'attaquerons.
Oui, mon général.
Major Reynaud, vous passerez la rivière par là avec trois compagnies et vous attaquerez par le sud-est.
Major Bentin, prenez-vous aussi trois compagnies.
Faites la vallée de l'est, vous servirez de réserve.
Moi, avec cinq compagnies, je vais attaquer au nord-est.
En avant !
Et l'opinion américaine fera de Custer un martyr de la civilisation.
En cédant Custer, qu'on avait surnommé le tueur d'Indiennes, venait de mourir.
Et la guerre va se poursuivre.
Sans merci, on détruit, on pille, on brûle les villages indiens.
En supériorité américaine, des chefs s'inclinent, acceptent de regagner les réserves.
Quelques-uns résistent pourtant encore.
C'est le cas de Crazy Horse.
On viendra lui offrir pour lui et les siens une réserve dans le pays des bisons.
N'ayant plus les moyens de combattre, il finit par accepter.
Comment ?
Quelques mois plus tard, on voudra mettre Crazy Horse en prison pour une pécadille.
Mais comme il refuse, un soldat va le transpercer de sa baïonnette.
Il avait à peine 33 ans.
Voilà la fin de celui qui fut le plus grand des chefs de guerre, le plus brave parmi les braves.
Quant à Sitting Bull et à Gall, contrairement à toutes les promesses faites, on les jettera en prison.
Buffalo Bill obtiendra leur libération pour qu'ils puissent participer à son spectacle.
Gall va refuser.
Je ne suis pas une bête de foire, je ne veux pas être exhibé en public.
Mais il y aura encore quelques résistances sporadiques comme celle de Joseph, chef des nez percés.
Un génie militaire qui, pour fuir la réserve, fait faire au sien homme, femme et enfant une retraite de 2700 kilomètres en 100 jours.
en livrant des combats couronnés de succès contre des forces bien supérieures en nombre,
mais à bout de force, ils devraient se rendre.
Geronimo et ses apaches vont encore mener une lutte mémorable contre les soldats.
À la fin des années 1880, l'ensemble des tribus indiennes sera parqué dans les réserves sous le contrôle de l'armée.
En général, un territoire aride, incultivable, sans intérêt minier.
Et ce sera la fin de toute résistance indienne.
Combien étaient-ils les indiens à l'arrivée de Christophe Colomb ?
Un million ? Dix millions ?
En cette fin du 19e siècle, il en reste 250 000, pense-t-on, dans un territoire réduit de plus en plus en peau de chagrin.
Ces nations formidables de bravoure, de majesté se soient trouvées réduites à l'état de pupille, à l'affligeante pauvreté, voilà quelque chose qu'il faut bien reconnaître et difficile à admettre pour un homme de bonne volonté.